il sent béni me regardez là est
franchement je vais vous dire un comme
quoi on peut être très beau en dépensant
beaucoup d'argent pour son physique
non mais c'est vrai regardez c'est vrai
regardez jean michel maire il a mis le
paquet il a dépensé tout son oseille sur
son corps il n'a rien lâché agnel tout
ce qu'il a dépensé c'est sur lui les
sujets cent cinquante mille roubles a
bien entendu c'est en robe et il fait
des trucs un peu partout les les poches
sous les yeux il a fait il a fait la
liposuccion le ton qu'il a fait l'année
peau il a fait la succion il à faire
les cachalots il a fait les paupières
non mais ça y est vous avez fait des
dons et d'en rêver non c'est du très bon
c'est vrai donc voilà pas très bien mais
je crois que des badauds jean-michel
quel est votre prochaine opération de
chirurgie esthétique et va peut-être à
cause du conflit une deuxième du coc
succion parce que j'ai quelques kilos
bah moi je pourrais pas je demande aux
téléspectateurs
moi je ne pourrais pas faire une émotion
parce que j avais fait vis ma vie de
chercheur fric et joie ils vont mettre
un tuyau ils vous ouvrent un peu ici
comme ça en dessous et vous m un tuyau
et vous voir et la grèce partie réservé
à 6o l inflation et endormi à wazemmes
et même voix mais même endormi tu vois
la grèce à qui s'en va travailler ça
tombe dans un dans une bouteille se
laisse que ça a vraiment marché
aujourd'hui dit la vérité
oui et non ça bah oui baoulé je vous
montre ma vas-y je montre vous savez pas
comment c'était avant
mais franchement raison beaucoup de
monde dix à qinze est bon mais c'est
beaucoup oui c'est beaucoup mieux quand
même parce qu'avec les pansements et
avec les pauvres annoncent à redire ma
fille m'a t-on un mais c'est énorme
non ça rigole pour nous bah oui bah ça
oui quand même
haoues avoir franchi la marche et
valérie martinez maire marc maintenant
c'est pas la peine de repartir encore
sur le billard non non non tu fais un
petit peu attention et turcs
l'allaitement calvillo pas pris là bien
sûr est maintenant je veux faire de cryo
la criée au masque c'est à dire c'est
que la clio la cryothérapie sûr mais des
plaques
c'est le froid qui gêne qui congèle la
grèce et qui du coup après la grèce
s'évacuer naturellement etc voilà si la
douche il paraît que c'est il paraît que
c'est le captain igloo qui fait ça